it's like a religious right for anyone
raised in texas
you roll into the gas station
look gorgeous
and pump your large vehicle to the brim
with that sumptuous
glistening gas that turned the state
into an energy empire
[Music]
smell that
[Music]
it's a rush of petrochemical pheromones
straight to the brain
the blessing of oil has given texas many
wonderful things
the great fracking prairies of west
texas
jr ewing
enron
and of course the petro paradise of
pasadena with its chemical factories
that celebrate humanity's ability to
harness and then dominate nature
imagine my surprise then to learn that
right here in houston
there were people like this
a pair of anti-petro hippies
these two guys say they can make things
like fertilizers and cleaning products
and plastics
without any oil or natural gas at all
and they say they can do it at this
factory which if you believe them
does not produce one ounce of waste
in honor of jerry jones and all that
texas considers holy
i decided to investigate this place and
these bold claims
i busted right on in to solution
[Music]
because houston is awesome
it doesn't really believe in zoning laws
you can drive through a neighborhood
like this
and then run smack dab into a chemical
plant in this case the headquarters of
soligen
the company has raised more than 420
million dollars so far
and counts noted science expert leonardo
dicaprio as one of its investors tell me
the big idea nobody's ever heard of
synthetic biology or any of this stuff
before what's the the very core thing
you guys are going after yeah i think
like
there's a few ways to think about what
we do at the simplest level
the question that we want to answer is
how do we use carbon dioxide to make
valuable chemicals and materials that we
interact with every day
the star of the show here is something
that solyagen calls a bioforge
the big idea behind all this machinery
is this you feed some enzymes with corn
syrup and because they're special
enzymes they kick off useful molecules
that can be refined and then used for
all sorts of tasks in short you're
making chemicals but using corn instead
of oil or gas to produce them
as solution sees it its technology
strips a lot of steps out of the
chemical making process
and most importantly for mother earth
eliminates all the noxious waste of
traditional chemical manufacturing i
actually grew up in houston i you know
pasadena is is not that far away and
it's it's famous it's like this
chemical industry town sort of notorious
for the smells and things that come out
of there um
you know if i think about the
traditional chemical process
what goes into that and why is it
notorious in some ways for all the waste
products if you think about
a chemical plant like the plants in
pasadena that you grew up with all
they're really trying to do is convert a
feedstock into a valuable product and
when you guys talk about feedstock
that's just the base thing that you're
starting with the raw materials raw
materials and the problem with the
traditional chemicals industry is
you can't convert your feedstock
directly to the product what happens is
you make this alphabet suit of other
side products these toxic emissions all
the smells all these waste streams
so really what the solution innovation
is gorbani coming together is about okay
well
what if you could convert a feedstock
directly to a product what solution is
claiming is that it has developed a
completely new way of making chemicals
that's both more efficient than
conventional methods and almost
disturbingly pollution-free okay so
sugar
water carbon go in yeah and then what
comes out at the end
our products yeah the product and no and
is there
water waste but it's kind of cleaner
it's just the products the product okay
so there's like nothing else the beauty
of like like the insight that we had was
just like you'll have no air emissions
no water it's a huge advance because of
like crispr and and precisely just being
able to
change the dna exactly change the dna
and then fundamentally the enzyme
in a way that lets it do things we want
my tour of solugen began in its labs
the scientists here must discover new
enzymes that will perform certain tasks
and then figure out how to grow and feed
them
this is where we actually engineer those
enzymes there's the physical wet lab
space but then we've got a server in
germany that is running millions of
computations on this little enzyme to
figure out how do we keep optimizing it
to make it better for that reactor
once we've designed that enzyme we now
have to express it at high enough tiders
that we can use it in our industrial
processes this is a small version where
we actually ferment the proteins and the
way we do that here is we let it live in
this fermenter and we feed it its
nutrients let it grow and as you can see
it starts this started like pretty clear
if i see how it's dark now that's means
the protein is starting to express
really really well
everything else that you see here is
downstream processing to separate that
protein out and
isolate it so we can put it into the
reactor
it all sounds easy enough now
but gorob and sean have been on a long
and winding journey to figure this stuff
out how did you two
meet and
come up with this idea in the first
place
yeah it's people think we made the story
up but we didn't right so like i'm
actually a physician scientist studied
cancer biology discovered really cool
like
reactions that make molecules in cancer
started with hydrogen peroxide and sean
was at mit doing his chemical
engineering phd on the production of
hydrogen peroxide at massive scales
using metal catalysts right yeah so
we're working on the same problem but
just from enzymes metals right it's
always just a story of luck like lucky
that we met lucky we had this idea then
what was really lucky is our first
customers saw our pitch to mit and they
said hey if you make this we'll buy it
and so
actually like we loaded our first
product in the back of my subaru and we
drove it to our customer in dallas like
a tank of something it was just a one
gallon bottle it was a mixture of
gluconic acid and peroxide that we call
bioperoxide so you'd be used for for
cleaning hot tubs okay yeah so we just
drove over it was not glamorous actually
yeah there's nothing glamorous but the
best part is like we thought it was
amazing so like we made this first sale
and then i told him i was like i'm gonna
quit my job and she was like
you made it like how big was it sale 200
bucks
and this machine so this this is like
the first thing that all stars worked on
yeah yeah so this is uh the original one
we've got i don't know why that's there
multiple times people have tried to
throw this away um but
yeah no i uh
gorba and i we we hand built this system
with this particular machine when you're
trying to develop the enzyme and your
technique there was just like nothing
like this that you could buy so there
are no enzymatic reactors okay so yeah
you can't go into google and be like i
want to buy an enzymatic reactor yeah
and where did you build this in
somebody's apartment or we we rented
some lab space behind lovefield airport
in dallas we rented some lab space and
then this was built from home depot
parts we actually had to take out
ceiling panels in the lab to fit it in
how long did it take you to do that this
was i would say this was probably a
two or three week build
and now these guys bizarre machines are
all grown up
and rather spectacular
and so this is the
first commercial bio forge
all the extra piping and everything i
mean what's going
what's going on all around us on the
sides from any point in the plant
you can essentially send material
anywhere else in the plant this is how
you build a zero discharge facility with
no waste stream
this is corn syrup i kind of jokingly
say that this tank contains 10 million
calories 10 million 10 million calories
yeah
so once it works its way through the
entire plant yeah then our end product
is stored in these tanks
and so we can essentially take our core
ingredients blend them with the material
in these blue tanks and then ship
finished goods into the concrete
industry into ag and into water
treatment
[Music]
how did you know that's supposed to go
off i built it
[Laughter]
much of what happens in this jungle of
pipes relies on solutions new age
enzymes but some of the action requires
old-fashioned chemistry in the form of
metal catalysts it's the metals and
enzymes combined that let the company
make just about any chemical known to
man
plastics gasoline whatever you want to
make it depends on what type of catalyst
you touch here can make a completely
different product profile
as this catalyst
like if you come to me as a customer
and say hey i want to make
nylon yup there is a catalyst in there
that when paired with an enzyme can make
nylon uh the starting precursor to nylon
so that's the beauty of kind of what
we're doing is like we've got this suite
hundreds of enzymes hundreds of metal
catalysts now it's just mixing and
matching based on what customers need to
make the product that they want
one of the biggest promises behind this
technology would come from sucking
carbon right out of the atmosphere and
injecting it into the bioforge as feed
instead of the corn syrup that they're
currently using solution thinks it knows
how to do this and is in the midst of
perfecting its techniques
basically that plant out there it makes
about ten thousand metric tons of
product but it removes about 30 greater
than 30 000 metric tons of carbon
dioxide
which is pretty remarkable on a mass
balance basis
how can we use synthetic biology and
marry it with traditional petrochemistry
techniques because we need both of those
things to really capture the essence of
using co2 as a feed stove we're working
with the corn story now which is a great
co2 sync but the reality is where we
want to go is how do we just take
that co2 from the air and make the
things that we want yeah the bio forge
only opened a couple of months ago and
some of the claims around it seemed
somewhere between bold and the stuff of
green tech fantasy
solution though is actually making
things already and does have some paying
customers our chemicals are used in uh
like concrete and building material and
like wood glue so like all the boring
things that make up the world around us
it turns out some of those chemicals
that are used are not super safe but we
might have an opportunity to replace
them with safer bio based
options because this is like the tip of
the iceberg if you look at what you can
do
with the bioforge concept you can go
after 90 of the molecules in the
chemicals industry
since i grew up in houston i knew what
needed to happen next
it was time to engage in the great
tradition of eating tex-mex food
it would be through the power of queso
and margaritas that i would learn how
this whole solution thing began with
sean and gorob running a rickety early
version of the bioforge all by
themselves
walter and jessie's style
[Music]
you know i mean it just seems like this
must have been a crazy
experience to be doing the breaking bad
thing and kind of seeing where it was
gonna just imagine where it would go we
were really just two guys running this
whole pvc reactor like i remember
one night in the lab i mean we were
behind lovefield airport a pretty seedy
area like we were just working and
someone threw a bowling ball through the
window
the question is like where they get the
bowling ball
at that beginning stage was this kind of
there's no you're seeing where it was
going to go or you're like we're going
to make a video it was trying not to run
out of money yeah but were you thinking
this could be a chemistry company or was
it just we're onto something interesting
i mean if we allowed ourselves to dream
the dream yeah it's interesting because
it's not that there was any particular
aha moment like i would say at the
beginning it's like i think we were
doing it because we really liked the
science we submitted
i think with 50 patents in 2020 alone
i know you guys are in a business and
you're in this to like make money you've
discovered this cool thing but isn't
this a little bit like when people
you know if you guys are as successful
as as you kind of hope to be and and
this does as much good as it could
wouldn't people be upset if you guys
have the
monopoly on all these recipes and
processes
i totally get that and i think that's
where we think a little bit bigger right
where it's like well what if
i i always use this example it's a silly
example
airbnb is the largest hotel but it
doesn't own a single property
uber is the largest cab fleet doesn't
own a single cab what if there's a
future where we are the largest chemical
company but we actually end up not
owning many chemical assets eventually
we give people access to these things
and so democratize access to like
this technology so anyone can
enable it and access it
these hippies do not have the i'll drink
your milkshake ethos of the best texans
but they do seem smart and well
intentioned
if the great roger staubach will forgive
me i'll even wish them
the best of luck
you